on this episode I get my first video
question I talked to mr. money and we
talked hashtags welcome to episode 7 fun
fact on the number 7 that is the number
of my starting quarterback Gino Smith
which reminds me just so everybody knows
episode 7 I'm in a very bad mood this
morning you might have seen my tweets
over the weekend
Dexter MacDougall our third-round pick
is out for the year D Milner are
starting best corner Dexter is also a
corner the Milner is a is out for four
to five maybe six weeks with a high
ankle sprain in our first six games we
play five of the seven best passing
attacks with rebus that traitor piece of
crap going to New England were depleted
back there and I'm just generally sad
before we go into the questions this
week I've been getting some emails of
people who are looking to get questions
answered that are a little more personal
so I decided to go innovation style I
don't know if you can zoom in here dear
Rach but right to the cyberdust I'm
going to answer some private questions
tomorrow which is Tuesday August 12
because I know people watch this all
time on cyber dice dust username Gary
Vee hit me up with your questions that
are personal because on cyberdust Mark
Cuban's kind of new venture big shout
with him the questions disappeared they
don't store anything they're playing up
that privacy some of you are looking at
some very personal questions so tomorrow
I'm doing a lot of driving around in New
Jersey from meeting to meeting and I
will be answering private questions
tomorrow morning on the dust as I like
to call it Gary Vee I'll see you
tomorrow
mark asks who are the idols of the
people that inspire you did you ever
have a mentor mark you know for people
that watch me or have followed me over
the last seven or eight years this is a
very easy answer I've been very hard
or about this I have never really been a
big fan of any business idols including
the before-mentioned more Cuban or you
know really the two entrepreneurs or
people that have ever kind of over
indexed to me where Walt is the and
Vince McMahon because they were heavy
storytellers and turn businesses out of
that I like that but to say they were my
mentors or I looked up to them there is
no Steve Jobs or Donald Trump's or
Carnegie's or there is nothing like that
in my life my life is really focused on
two individuals Tamara and Sasha
Vaynerchuk tomorrow from the HR people
skill foundation Sasha from the work
ethic you know we mentioned that in
Episode three or four so you know
they're really my only mentors that's it
hey Gary my name is Matt and I'm a
content creator who makes his living off
of YouTube lately a lot of people have
been asking me what my next step is
because they don't think YouTube will
last forever but I think it will only
continue to grow so my question for you
is should i hedge my risk by expanding
to other platforms or should I go all-in
on YouTube I'd love to know what you
think Matt how many of these people have
two million plus subscribers on YouTube
thought so so go with your gut you were
100% correct I've already made a mistake
on YouTube early in my career going to
VIP
full-time I've you know and I made one
right correction of jumping on it months
after came out in the first place
YouTube is the platform along with
Netflix and emerging other platforms
like a Vimeo or or an Amazon Hulu many
other things that will pop up along the
way YouTube is an anchor of video
content consumption and I think your
intuition is 100% correct and I would
keep doing exactly what you're doing I
see it going nowhere fast mr. money asks
what do you consider more valuable
enthusiasm or action mr. money before I
answer your question let me ask you a
question how does one get a name like
mr. money that feels a pretty remarkable
you know I carry money
I like it anyway action or enthusiasm
the truth is my friend M Squared can I
call you that mr. money the real answer
to that question really is both the
funny thing is I know tons of people
with massive enthusiasm and they can't
execute dick on the flip side I know
people that can execute a's on all their
papers but without that passion or
bravado or fire they're only able to get
limited return on that investment of
execution so to me I'm probably a 60/40
action execution 60 enthusiasm 40 I know
a lot of people might not get that but
the truth is I'm Way more proud of my
execution skills all this all this
charisma hides what I really am which is
a hardcore executor don't forget i dex
acute adalah visible or i ever hit the
scene i was already thirty years old
when i started Wine Library TV and
started that whole process and so I'm a
60/40 execution enthusiasm action I
might even be a 6535 heck as I sit here
maybe I'm a 70/30
TJ asks how would you suggest an indie
artist use their marketing money when
the royalty check comes in six months
later Jay first of all thank you for the
music today Big Ups to him and the
royalty check coming six months later
how do I think you should execute on
that is very simple I think you should
execute six months of patience if you
don't have the money you just wait for
it to come and then you execute there is
a lack wordplay J and everybody else is
watching there is a lack of patience the
thought that your royalty should come
six months later means that whatever you
wanted to do with that monies you know
to attack just has to wait six months
and so practically I just wait Thomas
asks cake or fine Thomas this is quite
simple for me this is pie I'm obsessed
with blueberry and apple pie though I
don't eat those kind of things anymore
but pi liz asks any tips on how to make
an unknown hashtag like hashtag mommy
energy popular and well-known
Liz first of all I love that name wife's
names sister's name uh second of all it
makes me sad Liz that uh that I have to
attack you in a good way uh with the
following question so everybody pour
yourself a little bit of sherry grab
your cigars if you like that kind of
thing
because this is a long-winded answer one
of the things I thought about over the
weekend is to give some real neat on the
bones on some of these answers you're
going to have your pie or cake questions
which I love by the way and I want more
of those by the way so ding those up
dang those up how does that mean I also
want to give long-winded answers to when
they deserve them and Liz I appreciate
you because you asked a question that a
lot of people are focusing on and I want
to put some real girth behind it so here
we go Liz first question back to you
little ping-pong action here is why do
you want it to Trent
so you get something to trend and the
interesting thing is as we all know
trending hashtags hashtags in general
are actually not very ownable right if
you create a hashtag anybody in the
Twitter universe can jump along and use
that hashtag more importantly when
hashtags you know trend we've seen a lot
of spam people jump in and use that
hashtag in their tweet to create spam to
create porn you know the funny thing is
is I always ask why so my question to
you is why Steve throw it out here you
can be part of this question what's the
hashtag appreciate money energy you know
by the way speaking of money energy I
spoke with Steve's mom on Twitter this
weekend and she mentioned that she liked
Steve on camera so that was a little
mommy energy you know Liz the real
question is why would you want mommy
energy to Trent do you feel that you
then benefit from it do not realize that
every mommy blogger anybody selling
products to mommies anybody authoring
mommy books can jump in use that hashtag
there is no ownership there's limited
upside you know the only reason i use
the askgaryvee hashtag is to find the
questions easier it's a utility it is
not
Marketing engine to take me to the next
level because I know it's so unabled and
so that is really the question to me to
everyone - who's watching which is why
would you want to own it in the first
place that's something that you need to
think about the why against any action
is really the thing that people are not
spending enough time on the strategy
matters my friends I really appreciate
you being a part of episode 7 the show
is taking off as many of you who've
watched all other six episodes know I'm
leaving for family vacation on Saturday
we'll be out the pocket for two weeks so
there will be a little hiatus as we go
right into football season which excites
me I want to definitely ask you for a
strong favor which is to subscribe up
and I also want to leave with a new
tradition which for all you hardcore
vayniacs is an old tradition many of you
watched my thousand and eighty plus wine
shows thousand with wine rbtv 80 with
daily grape know that I used to end
every episode with a question of the day
kind of ironic given the format we roll
with here but I'm going to start asking
you a question a day because I really
like what's going on in the YouTube
comments one of the great things for me
pride is I create an enormous amount of
friendships in the wine world because
people became friends in the comments
section I'm looking to do that again and
so thus by forcing a question add a more
interaction there people jump into
everybody's answers and it becomes one
nice gush buck and so the question I
have for you today first whenever on the
askgaryvee show is what's your other
personality in the video world are you
enjoying consuming content from give
them some love give her some love it'll
make me feel good you keep asking
questions I'll keep trying to answer
them
quote dingos up dingos up how was that
me thing isn't like tweet it out uh but
haha thing